it's an oops all nintendo direct edition
of gamespot news breath of the wild 2
gets a name and release date goldeneye
is back as are the pikmin all this and
more
the biggest news from today's direct was
its last reveal the release date and
name for the legend of zelda tears of
the kingdom the sequel to breath of the
wild was featured with some brief
gameplay featuring enormous structures
floating high in the sky and link able
to sky dive down from them and glide on
some sort of wing-like vehicle we're
sure superfans will analyze every frame
of the clip for weeks to come it's me i
am fans much of the game still remains a
mystery but all be revealed next year
the legend of zelda tears of the kingdom
launches the nintendo switch on may 12
2023 more than six years after its
predecessor the latest tactical rpg
entry in the series fire emblem engage
is something of a multiverse collision
game announced during the nintendo
direct's opening moments it's set in a
world that must face the re-emerged fel
dragon after a millennium of peace as a
divine dragon you lead the charge and
can summon past fire emblem heroes
including legends like marth and engage
with them for powerful attacks fire
emblem engage launches on january 20th
2023 and a divine edition featuring an
art book will also be available
square enix kicked off its current hd 2d
frenzy with octopath traveler on switch
back in 2018 and it's following up with
a sequel next year octopath traveler 2
features eight new characters this time
with intertwining stories across the
land of celistia path actions for the
characters will differ depending on if
it's day or night and the world looks
like it's a touch more modernized with
the additions of trains and other
technology you'll be able to play as a
dancer warrior merchant scholar thief
cleric hunter and apothecary which just
so happened to be the exact same classes
as in the first game octopath traveler 2
is out on february 23rd 2023 for
nintendo switch don't have enough
nintendo 64 games on the switch fear not
as a whole bunch are coming this year
and in 2023 nintendo reveals that mario
party mario party 2 mario party 3 pilot
wing 64 pokemon stadiums 1 and 2 1080
snowboarding and excite bike 64 are all
coming to nintendo switch online and
expansion pass members the first two
mario party games and pilot wings will
arrive in 2022 with the rest of the
mentioned games coming next year
additionally gold and i will be coming
with added online play although it
doesn't have a release date right after
this announcement rare shared that a 4k
remastered version of the game with
local multiplayer and a smoother frame
rate would be coming to xbox game pass
in the future as well while this sounds
like the better version to play keep in
mind online multiplayer will be
exclusive to the switch online edition
shigeru miyamoto really likes pikmin and
that means we're getting pikmin 4. the
game was announced with a very short
teaser during the nintendo direct which
didn't feature any gameplay but did
include a look at the new pikmin level
perspective for the action miyamoto said
in the presentation that the switch
makes controlling everything much
simpler so you should be able to focus
on your strategic decisions more this
time around it's coming in 2023 the
previously announced crisis core final
fantasy vii reunion got a release date
during the nintendo direct you'll be
able to play this overhauled and
remastered version of the psp game on
december 13th on not only switch but the
rest of the consoles and pc as well
featuring an updated combat system and
visuals that rival the recent final
fantasy 7 remake it's intended as a
faithful retelling of the psp games
events these are just some of the
highlights from today's direct check out
everything announced at
gamespot.com and that is it for today's
game spot news what do you think of
breath of the wild 2's real title what
is your favorite announcement from
today's direct let us know in the
comments below and we'll see you
tomorrow for more gamespot news
[Music]
you